and action
Jean Grae I called you in here because
you are a very important member of the
x-men thank you to invite you to take a
look
grasp or taste of a very important
x-men's member what me know I understood
what you said I cannot believe this is
coming out of your mouth
I'd like things would you make sex who
says that I'm saying it to you no but he
says that want the sprinkler system to
activate what is wrong with you
like your shins are on fire your
vagina's last vestige to keep the body
from burning ablaze as the leader of the
x-men
I expect much more from you I'd love to
give much more to you
trusts twists sniffs centimeter Center
high yard what is that even
I think it's Lionel Richie I'm clearly
the safest choice in this whole mansion
Cyclops his glasses fall off your feet
dead Wolverine prematurely ejaculating
because it's not as sensitive as another
man's I can grind it mash it thrash it
thrust it pick up stones with it what is
wrong with you hmm what is wrong with
you no I can't whoa
it's shag carpet down there if you run
your hand through it you might find a
triple-a battery or a small die in a
real cowboy yeah big fan of myself